and we've seen CNN take an epic L I was
going to ask you guys about the Trump
Town Hall actually what were your
thoughts on that I think uh I think he
crushed it I mean if you think about it
he got exactly what he wanted whether
you liked him or not every time he said
something the audience was clapping like
what what and then she kept getting more
and more and more irritated and then he
kept getting more and more and more cool
and there was like you know how you do a
two-hour podcast and you're like man we
got only three short clips out of this
one yeah and then you'll do one hour
podcasting like dude we got nice short
clips out of this one you know how many
short clips Trump got from that town
hall in 60 minutes yeah 40 30 it's like
well what would you do how come you
didn't do that well because I'm not the
president because I'm I'm not the
president haha hey so you know what let
me take these tweets out these are all
moments that go viral I think it was a
hit for him now the question is going to
come up with him and DeSantis of them
trolling the Santas over and over and
over and over and over is that going to
be the right strategy with the santis
who is liked and respected
I don't know it's different when you're
trolling somebody on the opposite side
that is not liked and respected you can
do that all day long like Hillary
Clinton wasn't liked or wasn't respected
so people love that stuff yeah but if
you do that model with a DeSantis who is
respected in Florida
we let's we're going to find out next
six or nine months if that's going to
work or not but this this is this is a
it's already started to be a very
competitive ugly fight
um and I think by the time it's over
with whoever ends up winning uh primary
they're already gonna have so many other
clips that Democrats going to be using
for the general election it's going to
be it's going to be wild but I think for
somebody that enjoys competition this is
going to be very competitive I mean do
you think the Democrats stand a chance I
think that no matter what like the next
president's going to be a republican you
you can never underestimate so that's
the problem I think that Republicans
have is they uh look for me in business
my mother's personality my dad's
personality we're talking about it today
in the house you know the mindset of
establishment and anti-establishment
okay the personality of a republican a
true Republican maybe a capitalist and a
communist okay that's probably a better
example so the establishment's mindset
is who they want to know everything
you're doing the establishment is that
girl you date that's like where were you
at who was it who's calling you why is
that a call from a block number why
don't you answer it respond back to that
text what was that call about that's The
Establishment they want to know
everything about what you're doing so
they're like so freaking annoying right
the anti-establishment girl you date is
like hey babe I gotta step out and take
this call okay it's probably his brother
it's fine hey babe I gotta go to uh the
store to get something I'll be back okay
no problem go for it do your thing The
Establishment girl's gonna be like why
do you have to go see somebody at 10 30.
are you going to go see a girl FaceTime
me where are you so they're so hovering
over you so the Republican side the
conservative side is not overly paranoid
yeah they're not the left is so overly
paranoid and willing to get deceptive
and dark the right's not willing to do
that at their levels again this is
purely anti-establishment and
establishment so I think only the
paranoid survive we'll see how paranoid
Republicans will be on this one it's
going to be wild yeah I think that's the
thing that that uh that town hall it was
like it was funny because it made Trump
look good right and then it was funny
too because he had just lost that civil
suit with that woman for the uh for the
sexual assault slash you know grape or
whatever alleged which I actually went
and read through that legal document
it's written not even like legal
documents written like a book it's
hilarious it's like literally written
like on this day Trump met her at this
store and he sexually assaulted her and
I was like what the is this a legal
document like whatever and I read it on
air a couple weeks ago and you know
after looking at like hundreds of legal
documents I was like amazed that this
thing actually made it through as an
actual complaint for a lawsuit and they
found in her favor and I was like what
the hell is going on here but he got
indicted by the state of New York right
for falsifying business records he got
um found liable right which everyone
says you got felt guilty which being
found liable and guilty are two
different things for the morons out
there for in a civil case and he's still
been going up in the polls so it's like
they're trying everything in their power
to make him look bad put him in jail but
it's not working do you remember when uh
UFC fight right Trump walked in oh yeah
I was waiting to see the response of
people how they're gonna react to him
right because of the whole indictment
all that stuff and people love it like
right after they legit stood up from the
top of their lungs dude the people love
Trump so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]